so how much did you grow from the show
and how much are you still hooking up
with people and doing your thing so it's
an interesting interesting question how
much did I grow I grew a lot from the
show obviously the second part of that
question is are you still hooking up
with a lot of people the what how the
show really helped me wasn't necessarily
in gosh how could I learn how to love
someone for what's on the inside and
communicate with them on a non-physical
way but actually what I got out of the
show is I really learned how to how to
love myself and get along with myself
and I understand I'm just a happier
person in general are you single I am
dating I'm dating give a girlfriend it's
not an official title but with this
quarantine it's it's long distance it's
it's an Irish and Irish girl yeah you
could yeah so Nicole and I have kind of
been kind of been talking and she
visited in LA and a little bit thing and
she's been making visits and whatnot and
why did you just look to the right isn't
it cool sitting with you know so Nicole
is not not here tonight but I did glance
my read because it is my bed where
things may or may not have happened
don't tell Lana but if we have a good we
have a great relationship : 9 she was
planning on coming out right around this
time but unfortunately with everything
that's going on so she your girlfriend
there's no label right now but you know
it's week maybe one day maybe Hey
well uh okay great I love it what made
you to connect that was a really
interesting thing because when we left
they retreat
Daquan I really didn't have a lot of
time to get to get to know each other I
was I was getting to know other someone
else in the show
and so we really didn't have a moment
when we finally left we actually spent a
couple days in a hotel in Mexico and we
just we bonded so so well we both like
to laugh and smile and getting the Sun
and drink and all that fun stuff and
she's Irish and I'm a you know I like
drink so voila um but they we have a
great we had a great time and we took
some we took some pictures together and
like we don't really look really good
together don't we and then from there I
was kind of like wow you know what yeah
and kind of grew from there so how many
times have you guys hung out in person
in the past year just a couple just does
Chloe approve you know I don't know if
anyone knows to be honest with you yeah
this would be a big scoop the rest of
the cast doesn't know no I don't think
anybody knows unless maybe I think Lydia
might know she's really good friends
with Nicole still I have been keeping it
a pretty decent secret on my end and why
is that
oh just uh you know we want to keep this
whole process we want to give anything
away to anybody we want everyone to
enjoy this this experience on Netflix
but you want to handle and not give away
any endings we want to you want to see
the growth and not make any any
preconceived judgments in
[Music]